the student college is a program offer
to Carnegie Mellon that allows students
to teach fellow students what the
strengths of Carnegie Mellon is so
multidisciplinary communities kids and
design because of architecture there's
given science kids in business and we
think that the state of culture talks
like a microcosm of all these industries
so the topics we include our early
history you know the routes where did it
all start who are the early influencers
we go into marketing campaigns we go
into production you cannot get speakers
talk about factories we really like to
take that me to touch upon everything
all the different types of cute we have
class for the midterm assignment we had
the students design and created their
own shoes on history its own design
features some story depending on what
the major was reflected in the shoe so
we just wanted to make sure that our
methods and the ways we presented the
material run could appeal to different
kinds of learners and and because we had
such a spectrum of sneaker enthusiast in
the class you know everywhere from the
true sneaker head to complete novices
with sneakers if we had to make sure to
keep everyone engaged the final for the
course we decided to have a splitting
community event because the essentially
four courses focused on sleep distinct
community as also we thought that we
would have been here on campus opens in
pulpits burg we have five million
collectors showing off the top 10
players we had boutiques local boutiques
selling things and showing their
merchandise we had artists performing
live hard just an act the answer then
also acted as a fundraiser or issue
raised in report on the soles for souls
which is a charity that accepts the
nation new to you sneakers that
victims of natural disasters in their
own countries so our price petition was
the parable sneakers you know it's not
about getting the newest sneaker it's
not about getting the most sought-after
sneaker it's about having a connection
with your shoes
you